my mind like thinking wait he's talking
all kinds of strange did I think
that I would actually be sitting here
one day with one of my kids getting
ready to get out I know I did
pot wasn't really something that I did a
lot when that wasn't really my thing
when I was younger
on occasion here and there and then I
got cancer started getting treatments
that really made me sick to my stomach
so I started getting it directly from
the doctor and now they have me on
cannabis oil so that's kind of fun too
I was kind of surprised when I found out
you smoked why wasn't your thing yeah no
it wasn't for a long time but then one
day it was gives me a lot less wallis
problems and like I know I'm getting
hammered the worst I do when I'm high as
I'm like all right let's watch something
on TV gotta say it is kind of weird to
be loading a bomb on my mom are you
gonna burn my eyebrows
[Music]
maybe you could do a little bit more why
metabolism does come into play here
what do you mean like slowed and
fabulous and fast metabolism - all right
so it's gonna take a little longer to
hit you
[Music]
what are you doing
Jesus I can bounce 20 feet it's now I'm
gonna be like Robocop this is so
weird you're just such a foot boy just
so you know back in the nineties he
actually created the first foot bomb
no I did not he did no it didn't created
that first design there was paper I know
but you had the vision
what oh hell yeah as far as I'm
concerned I can sit here for the next
few hours and just kick back and watch
what else happens at first I'm like this
is weird it's uncomfortable and then
you're like oh this is kind of fun and
it's hilarious at least I know I'm doing
it in the safe environment I feel ugly
and internally though with I'm loving it
and this is so wrong you're a loony bird
I started not feeling like she doesn't
deal in